Speaker 1: if you want an example. Of how
low the anti-choice rate is willing to go.
The Mississippi Republican speaker of the
House says that even if a 12 year old is
raped by her dad and is pregnant as a result,
she must be forced to carry the baby to term.
It's unconscionable. It's unconscionable. We
have an article. It's pretty, pretty vile.
12 year old incest victims should birth
dad's child. House Speaker Gunn says this
article is by our friend Ashton Pittman, who's
been a guest on the show. Mississippi House
Speaker Philip Gunn says abortion should be
illegal, even for a 12 year old rape victim.
Caring her father or uncle's child. He made the
remarks to reporters in the house in the hours
after the US Supreme Court struck down Roe v Wade
and Dobbs v Jackson Women's Health Organization.
I have video. I know that this is really,
really, really tough to watch. Take a listen.
Speaker 3: I believe life begins at conception and
every life is valuable. And that's that those
are those are my personal beliefs. So this quote.
That is that is my personal belief.
I believe life begins at conception.
Speaker 1: Now, life begins at conception is sort
of a copout. I don't know anyone who would deny
that there is a form of life at conception.
The relevant question is when are we talking
about a person? And in just about no other way,
are people like this guy willing to provide the
other personhood benefits to, uh, you know, a two
day old clump of cells that he would call life?
They don't want to provide child support. They
don't think it's the basis for citizenship.
You know, we've gone through it before. But that
position, a 12 year old, should be forced to carry
the incestuous pregnancy to term. It's sick
to even say it. It's not pro child and it's
not pro-woman. And then I realize, wait a second,
there is no woman. It's another child, another 12
year old child. But we're supposed to believe that
this is pro-life and that he has the interests
of the child in mind. Our friend Ashton Pittman
has been reporting on this and he writes, quote,
In Mississippi, poor mothers only have access
to postpartum Medicaid coverage for two months
after giving birth. This year, the Republican led
Mississippi Senate voted overwhelmingly to vote
to extend that to two months. Speaker Gunn killed
the bill, also adding later in a Twitter thread,
quote, Mississippi boasts the nation's highest
infant mortality rate, highest fetal mortality
rate, lowest overall life expectancy rate,
and highest COVID 19 death rate. Mississippi's
maternal mortality rate is 1.9 times higher than
the nation as a whole. Mississippi is a mess.
It's not an insult to the people. It's just the
facts, folks. Health care in Mississippi is a
disaster. Education in Mississippi is a disaster.
The economy of Mississippi is. It's a disaster.
And I feel bad about it for the people who
live there. And what they want to do is say
force 12 year olds impregnated by their
fathers to carry the pregnancy to term.
What they want should be criminal,
truly horrible people. Let me know
your thoughts. Is this even a shock to
you? Find me on Twitter at David Pakman.